[Música]
Qué tienen euclides Einstein de 12 años
y el presidente estadounidense James
carfield en común todos presentaron
pruebas elegantes para el famoso teorema
de Pitágoras la regla que dice que un
triángulo rectángulo el cuadrado de un
lado más el cuadrado del otro lado es
igual al cuadrado de la hipotenusa En
otras palabras a cuadrado más B cuadrado
= c cuadrado esta afirmación es una de
las reglas esenciales de la geometría y
la base para aplicaciones prácticas como
la construcción de edificios y la
triangulación de coordenadas del GPS el
teorema se llama así por Pitágoras un
filósofo griego y matemático del siglo
sexto antes de Cristo pero se conocía
así a más de mil años una tableta
babilónica de alrededor de 1800 antes de
Cristo enumera 15 series de números que
satisfacen el teorema algunos
historiadores especulan que los agrimen
egipcios antiguos utilizaban uno de esos
conjuntos el tres cuatro cinco para
hacer esquinas cuadradas la teoría es
que los topógrafos se extendían una
cuerda anudada con doce segmentos
iguales para formar un triángulo con
lados de longitud tres cuatro y cinco
según lo que dice el teorema de
Pitágoras esto tiene que hacer un
triángulo rectángulo y por lo tanto una
esquina cuadrada y los primeros textos
matemáticos indios conocidos escritos
entre 800 y 600 antes de Cristo
establecen que una cuerda estirada a
través de la diagonal de un cuadrado
produce un cuadrado dos veces mayor que
el original esa relación puede derivarse
del teorema de Pitágoras
Pero cómo sabemos que el teorema es
verdadero para todos los triángulos
rectos sobre una superficie plana no
solo para los que estos matemáticos
conocían porque podemos demostrarlo las
pruebas usan las reglas matemáticas y la
lógica existentes para demostrar que un
teorema debe ser válido siempre
una prueba clásica a menudo atribuida
Pitágoras mismo utiliza una estrategia
llamada prueba por transposición tome
cuatro triángulos rectángulos idénticos
con longitudes laterales a y b y
longitud de la hipotenusa c organice los
de modo que sus hipotenusas formen un
cuadrado inclinado el área de este
cuadrado es c cuadrado ahora reorganice
los triángulos en dos rectángulos
dejando cuadrados más pequeños a cada
lado las áreas de esos cuadrados son a
cuadrado y b cuadrado Aquí está la clave
el área total de la figura No cambio y
las áreas de los triángulos tampoco así
que el espacio vacío en uno se cuadrado
debe ser igual al espacio vacío en el
otro a cuadrado más B cuadrado
otra prueba viene de su compañero
matemático griego euclides y también
descubierta casi dos mil años más tarde
por Einstein de 12 años esta prueba
divide un triángulo rectángulo en otros
dos y utiliza el principio de que si los
ángulos correspondientes de dos
triángulos son iguales la proporción de
sus lados es la misma también así que
para estos tres triángulos similares uno
puede escribir estas expresiones para
sus lados
[Música]
A continuación se reorganizan los
términos
[Música]
y finalmente se suman las dos ecuaciones
y se simplifica para obtener ave
cuadrado Más C cuadrado igual BC
cuadrado
o a cuadrado más B cuadrado
= c cuadrado Aquí hay una que utiliza la
teselación un patrón geométrico
repetitivo para una prueba más visual
puede ver cómo funciona detenga el video
si lo desea para pensarlo
aquí está la respuesta el cuadrado gris
oscuro es a cuadrado y el gris claro es
B cuadrado el delineado en azul es c
cuadrado cada cuadrado contorneado azul
contiene las piezas de una oscuridad y
un cuadrado gris claro y prueba de nuevo
el teorema de Pitágoras
Si desea convencerse podría construir
una tabla giratoria con tres cajas
cuadradas de igual profundidad
conectadas entre sí alrededor de un
triángulo rectángulo si llena el
cuadrado más grande con agua y Gira la
tabla el agua del cuadrado grande
llenará perfectamente los dos pequeños
el teorema de Pitágoras tiene más de 350
pruebas que van desde lo brillante A lo
oscuro puede agregar la suya
[Música]
sabía que Algunos números se han
considerado lo suficientemente
peligrosos como para prohibirlos
profundice en la sorprendente historia
de los números ilegales con este video o
descubra los secretos matemáticos del
Triángulo de Pascal con este video